[gun banging]
Steven Mason: He probably
should've had some camouflage
on there and not just a
giant white bald head.
My name is Sergeant
First Class Steven Mason.
I'm the senior jungle instructor
for Jungle Operation Training course
at the Lightning Academy in
the 25th Infantry Division.
I've currently been the senior instructor
for two-plus years out there,
and I specialize in tracking and survival.
Today we're gonna be going
over some jungle-warfare movies
to determine whether or not they're real.
[soldier moaning]
This movie is ridiculous.
That guy has the inability to talk
just because he's being
pulled into something.
He's like, "Oh, oh, oh, oh!" [laughs]
[dramatic music]
I would say that the only time
that that would ever happen is, uh, never.
A camouflage top would be better.
He would have been leaving
dinosaur-size tracks.
So, a lot of people, when
they think about tracking,
they just think about, like,
a footprint on the ground,
but that's actually one of
the last things we look for.
Everything is so thick
that you're actually
leaving most of your imprints from, like,
your knee to your shoulder.
And that's where you're
kind of maneuvering around
and bending leaves and turning leaves
and leaving scratches.
So, I mean, he would have done
a significant amount of that kind of stuff
walking in and out of there.
[man yelling]
We teach a lot about water sources
and the way to move about them
and use them to your advantage.
I don't know that we teach
coming out of the water
and shooting people with a bow
and arrow that makes noise.
So, we like to use
waterways to traverse them.
So instead of having to walk through,
for example, that jungle
in the background,
that would be very taxing on the body
if you had to walk
a significant amount of
distance through that,
where we just teach you
to get in that waterway
and move until you think
you can get out again
and start walking, like they're doing.
But I would never say
that there's a scenario
where you'd have to,
like, hide in the water.
So if I was Rambo in this situation,
I would probably be in
the rocks where he was,
and that way if they do start shooting,
you at least have cover.
But once they come to you,
then that's it. That's game over.
I've been put in situations in the jungle
where they give you
a couple days or a week worth
of classroom environment,
and then they load you
up in the back of a truck
and they drop you off in
the jungle by yourself,
and you have nothing besides
a knife and a machete
for the next 10 to 14 days.
Survival isn't what people think it is
whenever they watch, like, Bear Grylls.
You know, like, he's excellent at it,
but he had to have gotten to that point.
But you just can't go into
the woods and be like,
"I'm gonna survive!" and then crush it.
I'm gonna say a two out of 10,
10 out of 10 for awesome.
Spook: Is this a double feature?
[soldiers laughing]
For God's sake, just lean your head back
and open your mouth!
Steven: That's pretty outdated.
I mean, we all chuckle
through all of them,
but when stuff actually hits the fan,
your brain reverts back to, like,
"Oh, my gosh, I saw this stupid video,
and that might save my life."
So, we do teach how to collect rainwater
in different types of leaves or bamboos.
If you were to just tilt your
head back and open your mouth,
you wouldn't get enough
water to do anything.
So, everyone talks
about the rule of three.
So you can go three minutes without air,
three days without water,
three weeks without food.
But that's a good thing about the jungle,
there's water everywhere.
There's a lot of vines inside of jungles
that just are filled
with water for that tree.
And if you can find those,
just cut that in half
and you have a couple quarts of water.
The rule of thumb for soldiers is
a quart of water an hour
if you're under a heavy workload.
Narrator: Your best friend is your knife.
Spook: Look at that, it's getting serious.
Steven: A knife is absolutely
the most important tool.
And knives are used for everything,
from building your shelter with it,
just using it to sharpen things,
to slash things, to cut things.
It has to be durable.
That's why we talk about full-tang blades,
meaning that the knife is
the full length of the handle
instead of just being the blade
and then a little bit
goes into the handle.
'Cause you need to be able
to put that into trees
and then bang a rock on it to split wood.
It just needs to be used for everything.
[helicopter whirring]
[Dieter yelling and laughing]
Even though it's right above you,
you probably would forget about security
and running back into the woods
until it actually was
time to get picked up.
And at this point he's
just trying to live.
He did exactly what we
teach soldiers to do.
If you need to get found
in a jungle environment,
you'd find a big open area
and try to try to create
something that's larger than yourself
so that you could be signaled.
You could light a fire
and then put a lot of green leaves on it.
It'll create a big plume of white smoke.
[helicopter whirring]
[Dieter yelling]
That's a jungle penetrator.
We actually use that
here at jungle school.
Same technology from Vietnam.
We're still using it today
'cause it's effective.
Soldier: What's your authenticator?
What's your authenticator?
Dieter: Rescue Dawn!
Soldier: Louder!
Steven: That's very realistic.
So, whenever you deploy,
you have to fill out some forms,
and there's a sequence of
questions that you have to answer
in case this scenario does happen.
You even have to put, like,
where your tattoos are on your body,
so when you do get caught, they, you know,
they're making sure they're
picking up the right person
and not someone they don't
want to be picking up.
That's the thing about the jungle
is that it can start
breaking you down physically
within 24 hours.
And you can look like this within a week,
and it all depends on your skill set
and how long you can survive.
Like, me, I think I could
survive pretty much indefinitely.
I would say that the last scene,
that's probably a 10 out of 10.
Chris: A fake human being.
Maybe I can see something I don't yet see
or learn something I don't yet know.
Steven: This is my absolute
favorite jungle scene
in any movie that's ever been produced,
because this sums up
what it's like to be
in the jungle, 1,000%.
You are just wet and miserable,
and you're wondering the entire time
why you made this life choice.
Oliver Stone, the guy
that made this movie,
he was actually in the 25th Infantry
and deployed with them to Vietnam.
It's usually pretty dark inside of there.
I've been in a lot of jungles
where you can't even see your
hand in front of your face
during night operations.
Kind of looks like, you know,
they have a spotlight on top of him.
[mosquito buzzing]
You just have to be good
at being uncomfortable.
There's no trick to that trade.
So, actually, the 25th,
we were the first ones to
field the new jungle uniforms,
a little bit lighter
weight that dry out faster.
We have jungle boots that dry out quicker.
[patting]
Soldier: Junior, hey!
Steven: I'm gonna be up scanning
for every little movement or sound I can.
So that keeps me up,
and I think that just the fear of
everything that's crawling
around on the ground
while you're down there
on it also keeps you up.
50% of everything is trying to kill you,
whether it be the plant life or animals.
In Vietnam, they have, like,
15 different poisonous snakes,
double that in poisonous spiders.
And then they have tarantulas.
So, yeah, you're just
constantly on the lookout
for what you don't want to
step on, sleep on, or grab.
And another thing is
there's only one person
up on guard on this patrol,
and that would never happen.
[guns blasting]
So, in Vietnam, the
average gunfight, firefight
was within 5 to 10 meters.
So the enemy was able
to get very close to us,
but we were also able to
get very close to the enemy.
Stealth in the jungle is paramount
to probably anything else.
You actually use the same things today
as you did back then.
So, technology has advanced a lot.
So the jungle really doesn't
give you that capability,
because satellites can't
penetrate through it.
The night vision can't get through there.
'Cause I was talking about how it's dark,
so, night vision actually
needs ambient light to work.
So you need a little bit of
light to make night vision work.
[wounded soldier screaming]
So, when you get shot,
if you're still in that
type of environment
and you haven't won the battle yet,
you have to figure out kinda
how to deal with the pain,
like he said, so that you're
not giving away your position.
'Cause you don't know if the
enemy has left the area yet.
Actually a lot of people,
when they get hit,
they don't even realize they got hit,
'cause their adrenaline's just pumping
and they're just so ready for it.
And then someone actually
has to tell them, like,
"Hey, man, you know you got shot?"
I've personally seen that, absolutely.
I would give this a 10 out of 10
just because this
reminds me of every squad
I've ever been in.
[gun blasting]
He probably should've had
some camouflage on there
and not just a giant white bald head.
Soldier: Keep your eye on the package.
Flea: Roger that. Holding.
Steven: What was accurate about this
is that they put a guy, a sniper,
up top who was kind of like
their topside security overwatch,
who was watching this scenario unfold,
who had coms with them, who could say,
"Hey, the situation has changed.
Don't go in."
The fact that you have to get
all the way up to the
village very stealthily
and then try to work your way
in one building at a time,
that's pretty accurate.
If you were gonna go
do something like that,
an operation like that, you
would be camo-ed head to toe.
But also them using suppressors,
that's pretty accurate.
[suspenseful music]
You would use hand and arm signals a lot
moving around the jungle.
A lot of them is just kind
of like the, you know,
halt, stop, keep moving,
standard stuff.
You know, these, these, stuff like that.
That's about it.
Using rally points and pointing places
saying, you know, like, "Hey,
this is something significant."
You're gonna have communication on you.
So, they have this cool-guy
stuff, with an earpiece.
They even have stuff --
this, like, throat mic,
so you can just press on your
throat and you can whisper
and it still comes across on
the other end just as loud.
So, yeah, everything's pretty accurate,
other than the face paint.
I would give this a nine out of 10.
[guns blasting]
As soon as they made contact,
they immediately rolled into the ditch
and then returned fire.
They got behind the nearest cover
and just started returning fire.
What was funny is that they were just
walking kind of in a straight line
across this open danger area,
which wouldn't have happened.
You could have done
another number of methods.
You could have bounded across it,
or you could have, we
call it hand railing,
where you just kind of
stay on the wood line and go through,
and then that way you wouldn't
have been an open target.
It is funny that he gets on the radio
and just starts calling in
and then rounds just start dropping.
Doesn't even give a grid.
Doesn't tell them where he's at.
Just says, "Tree line."
You're in the woods, and someone's like,
"We're in the tree line,
let's go!" [laughs]
Dan: Pull back!
Pull back!
Steven: I'm not sure that
the term "pull back" is an Army term.
We would say "break contact."
We'd have somebody covering our fire
while another group gets out of town.
And then once they get to
where they're gonna go,
they'll turn around and start shooting,
and then the next group leaves.
I don't think I've ever seen a situation
where someone yells, "Pull back!"
and then everyone just starts running
in the opposite direction.
So, the responsibility of the leader
is to command and control
the entire situation.
At no point, unless it's,
like, worst-case scenario,
should the leader of the entire patrol
be picking people up
and running with them.
He should be delegating those tasks
and then relaying all
the information to higher
and giving out guidance.
I would give this a six out of 10.
Blain: Come on in.
Ol' Painless is waiting.
[sighs]
Steven: After you've been in there awhile,
you can start to tell
that the weight of a,
let's say a tiger isn't
the weight of a human.
So you'll be able to distinguish the two.
Plus, a tiger knows how to
step, and a human doesn't.
Any snap or crack you hear,
you're gonna automatically
be on high alert,
especially if you think
the enemy's in the area.
[machine gun blasting]
If I had a Minigun in the jungle,
I would be doing that with it.
So that's about as accurate as this scene.
Someone might have an M16,
and they're just blasting off rounds
and it's just coming out as
fast as the trigger can go,
and they would never do a magazine change,
and he'll be in this firefight
for, like, 20 minutes.
Yeah, some of weaponry was correct,
but you would definitely
not be lugging around
this Gatling gun in the
middle of the jungle.
Those rounds that he had,
for the amount of
firepower that he put down,
that would have been,
like, hundreds of pounds.
So, the goal is to be as light as you can
for the longest period that you can.
You need to be very
aerodynamic and nimble.
I would rate this a two out of 10,
but a 10 out of 10 for awesome.
[guns blasting]
This movie is based on
one of the battalions here in the 25th.
It's based off 1/27 Infantry,
the Wolfhounds, from
their Charlie Company.
And this was when they had to
be deployed to Guadalcanal.
This is the type of terrain you'd see
when you're coming out of a jungle
and getting into kind of
the mountainous terrain,
where it's just, like, a
bunch of overgrown grass.
But they're trying to do a
frontal assault up a hill,
which was dumb in the first place.
[grenade pin pings]
[grenade exploding]
Probably wouldn't have happened.
Not really sure why he had
a grenade taped to his belt.
Yeah, normally you won't
be able to just pull
the pin itself
and the grenade still be on your body.
The distance was right,
the scenario was right,
just the way that it was executed
probably wouldn't happen in real life.
Keck: I blew my butt off!
I blew my butt off!
Steven: This is a pretty
realistic war movie.
I mean, even all the
way down to the way that
soldiers act whenever someone gets hurt.
It's still just a bunch of
guys trying to figure it out.
I would give the scene a
seven out of 10 for realism.
Soldier: I want you to
get me all the air support
you can get me on that mountain.
[helicopters whirring]
Steven: That was pretty
convenient that they had
two helicopters and an airplane on station
within, like, a second of the phone call
going out, or the radio transmission.
And they didn't even
have the grid out yet.
They were, like, still talking
and they were starting to shoot.
So, the reason that
they're using helicopters
and we decided to use
helicopters during Vietnam
is 'cause one of the only methods
to truly infill and exfill
from that type of environment
is to find that one little clearing
and then try to get as many
troops rallied to the same point
so that you can push from there.
The Vietnamese clearly
knew that that was gonna be
a point that they would try to infill,
and then they were dug into
the side of the jungle mountain
and then just decided to
fight down from there.
[guns blasting]
[soldiers yelling]
Everything is pretty accurate.
As soon as they hit the ground,
they just started running
to the nearest cover,
which was pretty far away,
'cause they got dropped in
the middle of a large field.
This is based off a real event,
Col. Harold Moore and the 1st Cav.
[helicopter whirring]
So, when a helicopter is coming down,
their entire body is spinning
and then they're kind of
oscillating all around.
So you don't even know
really where it's gonna land,
so you just don't even,
you hope that you would just
run in the right direction.
But as far as being in that helicopter,
that's just kind of hold
on and hope for the best.
I would give this a 10 out of 10
because I can visualize
what it would have been like
to be in this scenario,
and I just feel bad for everyone
that had to go through this.
[soldier yelling]
So, I love this scene a lot
because they're about to shoot a mortar,
and they're about to do
it without a sight on it.
And that's not the correct
way that you do it.
And then whenever they actually
hang the round and then shoot it,
it immediately blasts.
You see the blast.
So the time of flight
would have been, like,
the same as just a regular bullet.
The way a mortar works,
so, it has to come out,
go in the air, and then come down and hit.
That's not happening in this scene.
Also, I think that
they're giving corrections
without a sight on there.
So I'm not sure what
they're exactly correcting,
but that wouldn't happen.
There's a little tank running
around the battlefield.
Somebody would have probably already tried
to take that guy out.
[explosion blasting]
That's pretty accurate to what it is like
to see a tank get shot by another tank.
We had Shermans onshore at Guadalcanal,
and they were just trying
to reinforce the infantry.
But that's kind of the role
of a tank in this situation,
is just to try to flush
out all the larger targets,
so the ground forces can
continue to push forward.
But actually, at this stage of the war,
tanks weren't on ground yet.
'Cause we had just taken the beach.
[guns blasting]
That's also super accurate.
All the weapons are pretty spot-on.
The equipment was spot-on.
They're shooting Thompsons,
which is accurate for officers.
And the officer in this
scene has a Thompson.
This is a good scene,
other than the mortar.
I would also rate this a seven out of 10.
Soldier: Got the cheap
designer sunglasses.
Soldier: You sure that's him?
Steven: This looks like
a Kodak camera zoom.
I'm not sure what that is.
Soldier: He's moving.
Steven: You're always gonna have a spotter
and then you're gonna have a sniper,
and then they're gonna
be talking back and forth
about, you know, distance
and wind correction.
So, he just said,
"Two people, go walk down a hill."
Uh, [laughs] I'm not really
sure why he did that,
especially since five seconds ago
they were talking to each
other in normal voices,
giving each other corrections.
And then now they decide
that they want to be
stealthy and walk away.
You never want to give up on stealth
just because of distance.
[leaves rustling]
First things I tell
people about the jungle,
especially at nighttime,
it's almost so loud that it's unbearable.
So, the first night I
spent inside of a jungle,
this bird hadn't made this sound all day
and I didn't know what it was,
but at nighttime,
I still didn't even know
what type of bird it was.
It just sounded like this man
that was just, like, being
stabbed or something.
It was just like this, "Ah, ah!"
And I couldn't, I was
like, "What is happening?"
And then all of the other
animals start feeding off that.
And then it's just,
it's deafening, how loud the jungle is.
I would give this a seven out of 10.
The biggest thing that movies
get wrong about the jungle
is how long it actually takes to maneuver
from one location to the next.
You might watch a movie and it's like,
they're just walking for
days across the jungle.
Depending on the type of environment,
you might only move a
football field's length,
100 meters.